unlike our favorite comic book
characters the origin stories of silver
screen superheroes often involve more
steamed chicken breasts and stationary
bikes than Kryptonite and dead parents
but while the actors get paid to look
the part
it's the stunt doubles who take the head
the Falls and the rubber bullets or
without any of the glory let's go behind
the scenes to highlight some of these
brave performers who toil in the shadows
to bring the Earth's Mightiest Heroes to
life
Ingrid climbing Harley Quinn Ingrid
Clinic has been in the biz for a while
and definitely knows the rope she's done
stunt work on movies as diverse as
Superman Returns Australia and iron sky
but clinic really broke into the big
time as Evangeline Lilly stunt double in
The Hobbit an unexpected journey still
if she's had one defining part it's her
work as Margot Robbie stunt double on
Suicide Squad she and Robbie who's the
dancer herself became friends while tag
teaming the stunts for Harley Quinn they
even held a long-running contest to see
who could hold their breath the longest
underwater in the end they both topped
five minutes that's the kind of skill
that comes in handy when your job
involves crashing face-first through a
Lamborghini windshield in a water tank
will Erickson Deadpool over roughly a
decade will Erickson has built up a huge
Hollywood stunt resume appearing in
everything from Tron Legacy to wayward
Pines in 2016
Eriksen scored big when he landed the
part of Ryan Reynolds stunt double
during the filming of Deadpool along
with the team of other stuntmen Eriksen
helps bring our favorite regenerating
degenerate to the big screen in
particular Erickson was instrumental in
the SUV scene as the start of the movie
and for that Erickson you have a
heartfelt thanks Richard Bradshaw
Wolverine
Richard Bradshaw is Pro holistic stunts
career spans nearly three decades of
work on televisions and the big screen
you've seen his work in movies like The
Fifth Element Titanic and Tomorrow Never
Dies and his polls have been involved in
the production of Game of Thrones
serving as both a performer and the
show's assistant stunt coordinator
more than two dozen episodes in the
x-men franchise gradual worked as a
performer and stunt double for Hugh
Jackman in x-men 2 the last end x-men
origins Wolverine and Days of Future
past William Spencer
spider-man William Spencer earned the
named escape ninja on YouTube three
unusual skateboarding style but he
probably never thought his board would
give him a career in the movies the
amazing spider-man director Marc Webb
had other ideas
for his first outing with the webhead
Webb wanted to do something completely
different and that involved this Spencer
who'd spent a few years picking up spare
paychecks to the lights don't work on
movies like Jonah Hex and projects acts
didn't even make it to a spider-man
audition ultimately the filmmakers
couldn't find what they were looking for
and moved back around to Spencer who
ended up as Andrew Garfield's double for
both amazing spider-man movies tony
mikvah star wars trainee MacLeod got
started as a stunt performer in 2011 and
since then he's built up an impressive
stunt resume appearing in dozens of
television series and films with his
role in 2015 static world it seems mix I
found his niche as Chris Pratt stunt
double he went on to double for Pratt in
2016 passengers and again the following
year in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 a
role he prepared for by playing with toy
gun nice Bobby Holland Hanten Thor Bobby
Holland hantum is one of the most
in-demand done men in Hollywood he's
doubled to Chris Evans Captain America
Christian Bale in The Dark Knight Rises
and Ryan Reynolds in the Green Lantern
Command a few but if there's one gig is
especially proud of it's getting to
bring the Thunder as Thor across the am
senior from the costumes to the kick ass
stunt work Hanson loves everything about
this gig especially star Chris Hemsworth
whom he describes to Business Insider as
a legend saying Chris is in the best
shape of any actor of scenes he's got
huge arms and great coordination I've
never had
to train so much in my life three hours
each session twice a day six days a week
if Chris wasn't an actor he'd be one of
the top stunt men around but even after
all the highwire stunt is performed in
an Asgardian breastplate tangents
favorite stunt into the prison scene in
the Dark Knight Rises
he said I had to climb out of the prison
he's in and jump missed the landing full
a hundred feet and slam into the
opposite wall it was one of my first
ever high Falls a hundred foot earth
which is quite a nice speed to achieve
for a stunt performer Sam Hargrave
Captain America although Bobby Holland
Tanton has done some stunts as Captain
America
it's Sam Hargrave who takes the brunt of
the star-spangled beatings when he isn't
acting as demand behind caps mask he's
also serving as Marvel's resident stunt
coordinator and choreographer designing
some of the most memorable blowouts from
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
Captain America Civil War chances are if
one of Marvel superheroes takes her
knuckle to the face Hargrave is
responsible for it on some level clay
Pantanal iron man we've come a long way
from the chest shavings and paint on
latex Robert Downey jr. had to endure
for the first iron man faster between
CGI and stuntmen Robert Downey jr.
barely ever has a reason to put on the
Iron Man suit anymore which leaves clay
Fontenot as the only guy who still has
to suit up when the cameras are rolling
Fontenot doubled for Downey jr. in Iron
Man Iron Man sue and the Avengers and
he's done stun work on nearly 80 other
films as well including Django Unchained
guarding to the galaxy in all three
blade movies Fontenot is easily one of
the most prolific stuntmen in the
business thanks for watching click the
blue icon to subscribe to a YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
you